okay so the topic of today's video is
passive transport let's go ahead and get
started
so passive transport is the movement of
molecules across a membrane without the
use of energy energy in the form of ATP
now during passive transport molecules
move from a high concentration to an
area of low concentration now look at
the picture we can see on the left side
of the Box the yellow dots are more
highly concentrated and on the right
side there there's a lower concentration
of these yellow dots so over time if
these yellow dots represent molecules
over time the molecules will move mostly
from the left to the right until there's
an even balance and we call this balance
equilibrium
now when we say they move from a high to
low concentration we can also say they
move down their concentration gradient
these two phrases mean the same thing
from high to low concentration and down
their concentration gradient but a
concentration gradient is really the
difference of a substance between one
location and another so in my picture
here I have a scenarios here here
scenario a on the left there's eight
dots and on the right there's only two
scenario B there are six dots on the
left and four dots on the right so my
question is which scenario A or B shows
a greater concentration gradient
well in both cases the molecules are
going to move really from the left to
the right it's going to take four of the
yellow dots to move to the right in
order to get to equilibrium
but in scenario B only one has to move
to the right to get to equilibrium so
the answer of my question is scenario a
has a greater concentration gradient
there's a difference of six and there's
a difference of two for scenario B so
again the answer is scenario a has a
greater concentration gradient compared
to a scenario B so I hope that helps
identify what a concentration gradient
is
now examples of passive transport
include diffusion
osmosis and facilitated the diffusion
that's what the rest of this video is
going to focus on and they all have
something in common if you follow the
picture there's a high concentration on
the top of the membrane and a low
concentration on the bottom so over time
the the
blue hexagon molecules will move until
there's a equal balance of them this is
what passive transport is
so let's talk about diffusion first the
movement of dissolved molecules in a
fluid or in a gas from an area of high
to low concentration well here's a cell
and the cell has some oxygen in it and
around it now well the oxygen mostly
enter or exit the cell I hope you
realize most of the oxygen is going to
enter from a high concentration to an
area of lower concentration some of the
oxygen actually might leave and exit the
cell but the vast majority will enter
until there's this balance known as
equilibrium
and this is how cells obtain their
needed molecules Let's Pretend these
black circles represent something that
the sound needs like a nutrient well
they're diffusing from a high
concentration on the outside to a low
concentration on the inside
diffusion is also how cells get rid of
unwanted waste like perhaps these black
circles represent in a waste and notice
how they're diffusing from an area of
high to low concentration
you know diffusion also explains how a
fart will travel across a room look at
the student in the top right up you just
let out a fart so right now there's a
high concentration of fart molecules
around this student but over time they
will diffuse to a lower concentrated
area which is all throughout the
classroom and eventually other students
begin to notice it as it diffuses and
they can then smell it
and So eventually diffusion continues
and then there's a balance that's
reached an equilibrium this is where
there's an even balance of molecules
and in my picture here in which area a b
or c can we see equilibrium help you
realize that's picture C
well when we look at diffusion we can
really look at how we breathe and
understand how a diffusion plays a role
in this process so imagine this of this
woman here she inhales a breath of o2
oxygen well if we follow that oxygen
we're going to see that diffusion plays
an important role
so as we follow the oxygen the oxygen is
going to spread into the woman's lungs
you know down her trachea through the
left and right bronchi and into the
woman's lungs and in our lungs there are
these little air sacs called alveoli
millions of them in each lung that fill
up with oxygen
so here's one of those air sacs and so
oxygen will fill the millions of air
sacs the alveoli that are in each lung
now ask yourself
where is the high oxygen concentration
right now I hope you see it's in the
alveoli whereas the low oxygen
concentration it's in the little tiny
blood vessel called capillaries that are
just on the outside of the alveoli
so oxygen will diffuse into the
capillaries and then because your
heart's beating your heart will pump
this oxygen-rich Blood all around the
body let's go follow this oxygen
and here's some of the oxygen that just
diffused and it's traveling through our
bloodstream and now notice the Cell at
the bottom cell X cell X like every
other cell needs oxygen but it's not in
direct contact with the blood so how
does cell X get oxygen well ask yourself
where is the high and low oxygen
concentrations
I hope you see the high concentrations
in the blood flow and the low
concentration is in all the cells
surrounding the blood even cell X so
through diffusion oxygen begins to
diffuse from a high concentrated area to
a low concentrated area and cell X can
get its oxygen just like all the other
cells in the body
but you know the reverse process is true
with carbon dioxide over time your cells
will generate carbon dioxide waste and
too much can become fatal so it's got to
get removed and look what's happening
these cells have generated carbon
dioxide waste how do we get rid of it
well ask yourself where is the high
carbon dioxide and where is the low
carbon dioxide concentrations well the
high concentration is in the cells the
low concentration is in the bloodstream
so carbon dioxide will diffuse into the
bloodstream and your heart is
continually pumping this blood in this
case the carbon dioxide is going to go
back to the lungs
and here comes the carbon dioxide back
to the alveoli the lungs those air sacs
that are in our lungs
and if I were to ask you where is the
high carbon dioxide concentration I hope
you realize it's in the capillaries
whereas the low CO2 concentration it's
in the alveoli so once again diffusion
will occur and the carbon dioxide
diffuses into the alveoli so we can
exhale it and get the carbon dioxide out
of our system
and so as the woman exhales the carbon
dioxide is pushed up her trachea and
eventually out her nose and mouth we
have a muscle underneath our lungs
called the diaphragm that helps to Aid
in this exhaling process
add the carbon dioxide is expelled into
the into the atmosphere and this process
repeats with every breath she inhales
oxygen a moment later she exhales carbon
dioxide
she inhales oxygen and a moment later
she exhales carbon dioxide but diffusion
plays an important role in the Journey
of oxygen and carbon dioxide
well if we shift focus and talk about
osmosis osmosis is the diffusion of
water specifically water from a high to
low concentration
and so let's talk about a certain type
of water maybe you've heard of what's
called distilled water
well here's a distiller right here this
is how you make distilled water you can
take some water you can boil it and the
heat will turn the water into a steam
the steam Rises and eventually cools and
condenses and the water that's collected
at the end is pure water it's distilled
water or pure water any contaminants and
impurities have been left behind in the
original boiling container so distilled
water is a hundred percent pure water
so here's a container of distilled water
it's a hundred percent pure water which
means there's no solutes in it so
distilled water is again 100 pure water
it's got no solutes in it now imagine if
I place a cell into distilled water
the cell has in this example 90 water 10
percent solutes my question is if only
water molecules can pass in and out of
the cell what's going to happen to this
cell over time
well I hope you see that through osmosis
water will go from a high concentration
of 100 to a lower concentration of 90
percent water will diffuse into the cell
and it will probably eventually swell
and so what we have here the water
inside of the cell is an example of a
hypertonic solution a hypertonic
solution is one that has a greater
amount of solutes now there's only 10
percent solutes but that 10 percent is
greater than the zero percent on the
outside and so the solution on the
outside is called a hypotonic
environment a hypotonic solution this is
a solution with a lower amount of solute
so you have to compare the two compare
the solution in the beaker to the
solution in the cell
let's do another example using salt
water now here's a container pretend of
salt water and salt water has a high
amount of solutes in it namely salt
Let's Pretend This salt water is 80
water 20 solutes let's bring back that
same cell from a moment ago the cell has
90 water 10 solutes the question is
what's if only water can pass in and out
of the cell what's going to happen to
the cell over time
through osmosis the cell is going to
lose water from a high concentration of
90 percent to a low concentration of 80
percent it'll probably start to shrink
and shrivel as it loses water
now the water inside of the beaker in
this example is hypertonic it has a
greater amount of solute it's 20 percent
is a greater amount of solutes than 10
percent and the solution inside of the
cell in this example would be hypotonic
notice it's reversed from the previous
example
now here's some practice here's a beaker
filled with 70 water 30 solute if we put
two cells in the water I want you to try
to answer these questions right here
pause the video I'm going to go over the
answers in three two one
so if only water can pass in and out of
the cells which of these two cells is
going to swell well I hope you realize
water is going to go into cell a because
of osmosis and water is going to come
out of cell b because of Osmosis so
which cell is going to swell that's
going to be cell a because water is
going into it now relative to the
environment which cell is filled with a
hypotonic environment
hypertonic means it has greater amounts
of solute so cell a is hypertonic
compared to the environment of hypotonic
but now look at cell b
cell B's environment is hypertonic and
inside is hypotonic hypotonic is the
environment with a fewer solutes 20
percent is fewer solutes than 30 percent
in environment so I hope you said cell b
here's another practice problem right
here here's ours our container of water
with three cells in it
pause the video try to answer these
questions I'm going to go over the
answers in three two one
so if only water molecules can pass in
and out of this cell number one what do
all three cells have in common
I hope you realize there's a few ways
you can answer this but all three cells
are filled with a hypertonic solution
in other words they're all going to gain
water water is going to go into all of
these cells because of Osmosis they're
all going to swell
question number two relative to the
environment which cell has the steepest
or the greatest concentration gradient I
hope you identified cell C there's a
bigger difference between the
environment of the beaker and the
environment of cell C
and then for number three which cell is
going to reach equilibrium the fastest
that's going to be cell a because it's
closer to equilibrium already it's not
exactly at equilibrium but it's closer
to equilibrium so it should reach
equilibrium the fastest
okay and then the final topic is
facilitated diffusion now the word
facilitate simply means to help so
sometimes diffusion needs help
and in facilitated diffusion molecules
can enter an exit a cell with the help
of various protein channels that can be
found within the cell membrane
well carbon dioxide is a really small
molecule it doesn't need help it can
just slip right through the cell
membrane
same thing for oxygen it's a real small
molecule it doesn't need help it can
just slip right through the cell
membrane
so what are some examples of molecules
that need help well one would be larger
molecules like glucose glucose is made
up of 24 atoms six carbon 12 hydrogens
and six oxygens it's a bigger molecule
it's just too big to slip right through
the cell membrane
but what will happen is it well glucose
can travel through these protein
channels to go from the outside of the
cell to the inside of the cell so with
help the molecules can still diffuse
into the cells
other examples that need help are
charged ions or charged molecules so the
example right here is potassium
potassium is really small it's only one
atom in size it's small enough to fit
through the cell membrane but because it
has a positive charge and because the
cell membrane also has a charge the cell
membrane kind of repels the potassium so
it can't just go right through the cell
membrane
but the potassium can also use different
protein channels than the ones that
glucose was using so through the cell
membrane now these little protein
channels that molecules and ions can
enter and exit
and because this is facilitated
diffusion no energy or ATP is used
there you go I hope you found this video
helpful try this practice quiz if you're
in my class I'm happy to check your
answers before class or after class one
day thanks for watching